[Musique]
c'est une journée comme toutes les
autres depuis le début du confinement
pour des cra cette jeune styliste de la
banlieue nord de tunis
comme de nombreux tunisiens et face à la
crise pension de son activité
elle a décidé de mettre son savoir faire
au profit de la communauté celle qui
tous les jours doit faire face aux
coronavirus les mêmes gestes qu'elle
réalise un rassemblement pour
confectionner ces masques et les
distribuer gratuitement
je vois beaucoup de personnes dehors
s'en va ce que je vois surtout les
employés municipaux sans masque il y
avait même des personnes qui n'ont pas
les moyens de s'en acheter
j'ai donc décidé de confectionner des
masques et de les distribuer dans un
premier temps aux employés municipaux
qui sont en première ligne notamment
avec le ramassage des ordures et c'est
après que j'ai eu l'idée d'élargir cette
distribution aux personnes les plus
nécessiteuses et aux bénévoles dans la
mesure où j'ai dû fermer mon atelier et
j'ai décidé de déménager mon matériel
chez moi pour éviter tout contact et me
concentrer sur la réalisation de ses
basques aujourd'hui je dois finir une
cinquantaine que je vais aller livrer au
croissant rouge
[Musique]
employée de mairie
le scout ou encore croissant rouge la
livre ses créations quotidiennement et
directement
l'occasion pour elle d' échanger avec
ses héros du quotidien et de puiser
l'énergie nécessaire pour continuer sa
mission
une initiative très appréciée pour ses
bénévoles du croissant rouge
strasbourg en pleine crise du courant
navires us on a besoin de tous les
efforts ma société civile de leur aide
l'écart à nous seuls on ne peut pas
gérer toute cette situation on remercie
toutes les personnes qui contribuent à
notre protection surtout que nous
travaillons dans un espace clos depuis
le début de la pandémie les initiatives
citoyennes se multiplient à travers tout
le pays face aux actions du gouvernement
jugée insuffisante
ils sont nombreux ces jeunes a contribué
à cette lutte contre le virus qui a
fragilisé tout un pays déjà frappé par
une crise sociale économique ou les
jeunes sont en première ligne chez les
scouts de sidi daoud dans la banlieue
nord de tunis venir en aide à la
population est un devoir inscrire dans
leurs valeurs chaque jour ils se
réunissent pour faire un point avant
leur mission de décontamination de leur
quartier en matant venait de finir votre
débriefing ici chez les scouts de tunis
c'est le début d'opérations du coût de
nos élites
sa mission c'est comment on va bouger
que c'est qu'est ce qu'il va faire
qu'est ce qu'il a à faire
comment protéger hui ses camarades aussi
lors de cette opération
ici tous les ventes volontaires en une
idée sur le coronavirus comment protéger
comment se protéger en vis-à-vis ce
virus est et comment protéger leurs
familles et le reste du citoyen de sidi
des masques blues ou encore désinfectant
ils sont parés à s'attaquer à une
nouvelle parcelle de leur commune un
devoir citoyen que beaucoup d'entre eux
prennent à coeur vous nous expliquer un
peu ce que vous faites là bas j'avais
nous sommes en train de déserter ce
quartier après avoir fait de marcher ou
très important où se rassemblent
beaucoup de monde
c'était notre priorité aujourd'hui on
s'attaque donc à cette rue là c'est une
mission très importante pour moi et je
m'en souviendrai toujours le jour où je
me suis protégé que j'ai protégé les
autres voilà pourquoi je suis là
aujourd'hui en tunisie les 15-29 ans
représentent 24 5% de la population
une tranche d'âge de plus en plus
mobilisés dans la société civile est
bien décidé à participer à cette lutte
collective contre le corps d'un virus